Speaker 1: Republicans are now desperately
rethinking if and how they should be talking
about abortion during their campaigns because of
the disastrous flop of the 2022 midterms. Remember
that in 2022, historically speaking, Republicans
should have done unbelievably well. They should
have probably taken control of the Senate, which
they did not. They actually lost ground in the
Senate going from 50 to 49 seats. They should have
taken control of the House with a much greater
margin, but they did not. And now Republicans
are in the situation of having to rethink their
strategy. There's an interesting Hill article
by Julia manchester which says Republicans
are recalibrating their messaging on abortion
after Democrats successfully used the issue to
galvanize their base and win over swing voters in
2022. While the GOP largely focused on the three
pronged message of combating rising inflation,
crime and the flow of migrants over the border,
exit polls showed abortion was a top priority for
voters at the ballot box. Republican Committee
Chair Ronna McDaniel said, quote, It was probably
a bigger factor than a lot of people thought.
We've got to get conversant on that. We can't just
do an ostrich method and pretend that it doesn't
exist when Democrats are spending $30 million
on that message. According to exit polling,
27% of voters said abortion was the most important
issue coming in only behind inflation at 31%.
So there's a few things to understand here.
In general, abortion is a deeply polarizing
issue. And so there's always a risk when you
campaign on either side of a really polarizing
issue that you're going to alienate a large swath
of the electorate. That's just a general thing
with polarizing issues. The issue in particular
with abortion for Republicans is that not only
is it polarizing, but the country continues to be
more and more and more in favor of abortion being
legal in most cases. And in fact, we've we've
seen a steady increase in the Roe v Wade era,
which ended a few months ago in Americans,
generally speaking, saying, yeah, in most cases
this should be legal. And so when you take that
away, as the Supreme Court did as a right and then
Republicans can can campaign on how great that is,
it's not necessarily going to be useful to you.
Secondly, abortion is a distraction, in a sense,
to more pressing issues that Americans feel that
they are facing in the sense that Republicans
could be focusing on the economy, health care,
education and foreign policy without the drag
of their position on abortion being there. And
what I mean by that is the following. Republicans
tried to make their campaigns to a degree about
inflation and the border and Biden's bad and
whatever, and we can adjudicate whether that's
a good or bad idea on its own. But they were
dragged down by the knowledge and the timing of
the Roe v Wade reversal by the Supreme Court. And
so many Republicans saying that that was a really
great thing. And so that was also a problem for
Republicans. And the maybe last part of this is,
of course, I'm pro-choice, you all know that.
But the American people are mostly pro-choice.
And so the Republican position on abortion with
some Republicans saying there should be some
exceptions. But putting that aside, it's a flawed
and misguided ideology. And as I mentioned before,
the position of Republicans is based on the
assumption that abortion is morally wrong,
it should be banned, it should be illegal.
Maybe it's murder in many cases, regardless
of the situation or the circumstances. It ignores
the reality that most Americans don't see it that
way. And of course, it ignores the reality that
sometimes abortion is necessary. It's an important
option for women to have, and it should not be
something in which the government is involved. So
on so many levels, this is a misguided strategy.
So what's going to happen next? We saw it backfire
at the ballot box in part. There's lots of things
that we can blame for what happened in November,
but to a degree, the position on abortion
of the Republican Party was a factor. So
do they stop talking about abortion? That's
a problem because Republicans still raise a
disproportionate amount of money from religious
voters by saying we are against abortion.
What do they do if they don't talk about it?
There's a risk talking about it. The way they have
talked about it is also a risk. So in total, the
Republican Party's position on abortion is flawed.
Medically. It's flawed morally and ethically,
but it's also flawed strategically. If they
want to win elections and be successful, they're
going to need to do a rethink. I don't know what
that rethink should be. I don't care. I don't
want them to win. So it's not for me to start
giving them advice. But we'll have to track
and see whether in some of the 2023 elections,
abortion takes on a sort of different tone from
the Republican Party and certainly going into
2024. Let me know if you do have thoughts.
How should the Republican Party straddle
being against abortion? But the reality that
increasingly the country is in favor of it.